[Music]
my name is Scott met wooden burg I'm a
product manager on Google cloud and
today we're gonna talk about a little
bit about architecting for performance
when you're building large-scale
applications in the cloud just a quick
process note like you I think you've
seen these slides probably on some other
talks but this session is it has a dory
so you can pull up the app like the
google cloud next to app click through
find this session click through to the
dory Q&A and submit questions like kind
of throughout the session and as you as
you think of them rather than trying to
remember them till the end and and we'll
have a take at the end the Q&A session
we'll take questions both from live
questions from the audience there's
microphones that you need to come up to
and we'll alternate between that and the
Dory if there are questions on the Dory
as well so just keep that in mind and
we'll let's get going so I just give you
a little bit more info about what I'm
going to cover I'm gonna start with a
little bit of discussion around the
state of what Moore's law looks like
today what how it's how the trends been
going the last few years what the
implications are for scale-up
applications or applications depend on
scaling vertically we'll also talk about
what kind of challenges get introduced
and and you have to start dealing with
when you start reacting form or scale
out type applications and and tracking
performance in those types of systems
and we'll do a real-world example or
talk through some examples from
real-world application which I'll talk
about it when we get to it and then at
the end we'll kind of cover a little bit
about you know once we've once you've
kind of got your performance well
understood what kinds of things you can
think about next and and kind of
optimize for and that sort of thing so
this graph kind of shows the the Moore's
law like kind of the big question is you
know you've seen articles and Moore's
law is dead a bunch of information
around that is that technically true
well if you if those who remember
Moore's law is about transistor count
doubling every 18 months / 2 years
depending on who you talk to
so you can see from this graph like
transistor count continues to go up so
that part of Moore's law is not really
dead but some of kind of the important
characteristics that also used to scale
along and in that roughly that frequency
are no longer holding and so for example
like kind of single thread performance
like as measured by like you know your
typical specint cpu type benchmark has
continues to increase but not nearly at
the same rate as it used to the single
the frequency of the CPUs themselves as
well as the power that you can actually
that they can actually draw has sort of
plateaued off there's some reasons for
that there's call it's called the power
wall it's pretty easy it's basically
about getting that much power to a small
small area of the chip the small die
area without basically melting the whole
thing the and then the number of logical
cores continues to increase with a
transistor count which is good but that
kind of signals even at the cpu
microarchitectures layer you know
they're already kind of moving away from
the vertical scaling you know super high
frequency higher and higher frequency to
more of a scale out of configuration
architecture where they're just adding
more and more cores and so taking
advantage of parallelism parallelism at
the CPU level to get more performance
out of out of the same amount of power
so how does this impact like large-scale
application architectures you know
basically any of scale-up components
that you have become your performance
bottlenecks pretty quickly especially as
you you know if you're building a
service that serves you know it's a
mobile app or something that serves
10,000 users you can probably do that on
a sequel dateable database running on
one VM if you scale that up to like a
hundred million users that's gonna fall
down pretty quickly so large-scale
application developers are people that
are trying to evolve their architectures
to support a larger very fast-growing
user base are having to you know figure
out how to react detect to their
scale-up components and systems to be
more hard horizontally scalable or scale
out so examples include like sharding
your user base or your users across
multiple shards of a database maybe
geo-specific so you've run you know
you're all the users and Europe are in
one database all the users in the US are
in another database that's one example
you can do the same thing with front
ends like you kind of build you know get
rid of the state that sits in your front
ends and and do scale out like you've
run multiple front ends to terminate
your inbound client connections and
things like that but all of this also
means that as you've changed the
architecture or if things your system
becomes a lot more complicated it gets a
lot harder to understand and reason
about what the overall system
performance looks like and how to
troubleshoot that there's a good analogy
to if you think about like a high
availability building high available you
systems you've got to have redundancy
like you want to get rid of single
points of failure 'z you can kind of use
a similar analogy for your like when
you're thinking about performance of
your application or workload in that if
you've got a scale-up component that
becomes a single point of a performance
bottleneck
it doesn't quite roll off the tongue
like the single point of failure but it
gets the point across and kind of gives
you a good mental model to keep in mind
so kind of going for a quick example you
know if this is just a basic web browser
right it's just serving some content and
you got two variations like you've got
on the Left you've got one that's where
the database and the web server and all
the tools and everything are sitting on
one machine it's pretty easy for me to
measure like total QPS or total you know
requests per second that I can process
here I can use my standard operating
system tools like on Linux like top and
and whatnot to see what system like is
the database the thing consuming all the
CPU is it my web server a web server or
whatever so that's pretty easy to
understand and figure out where your
bottlenecks are and even in the example
on the right where you've kind of split
that out you've now got two machines one
that's dedicated just for the database
and and one that's then running your web
server tools you're still you know
you've only got two places to look to
kind of figure out what your performance
you know what's currently limiting your
performance so you know as my number of
connections
it grows do I see a plateau I need to go
look at what system is the thing that's
that's causing that and how to have a
architect to fix it on the other hand if
I'm building something
quite a bit more complicated like this
is an example of a real-time ads bidding
application you know at what point or
where if my bids per second are you know
hitting a cap and or the latency of each
bid is is increasing as my as my number
of bids is I try to submit white goes up
how do I know where in here
the bottleneck is like so you know it
could be maybe it's at the load balancer
probably not it could be I'm not adding
enough compute servers the bidding
servers I might not be quickly scaling
and adding enough of them it could be
kind of many of the different components
here and so understanding which one it
is it becomes a lot more difficult and
then once you kind of not just
performance of your application but also
you know am i spending too much money to
deliver this like how do i you know if
in a system like this what's the most
likely this is genomics analysis so
you've got a bunch of gene sequencers
that are you know doing and a gene
sequencing analysis dumping all that
data into VMs to ingest into this big
HPC cluster that also runs on VMs you
know of all these systems which one is
probably the most likely that I'm
overpaying for like or that I can you
know optimizer tune to be more efficient
or maybe try a different type of
hardware component like you know
optimize my computation for GPUs for
example and and if I can get more
throughput that way that might end up
being cheaper than continuing to add
more CPU VM so that's just another
example so earlier I said we were going
to talk through some examples from the
real world because I think examples
really help kind of cement these ideas
and I'm gonna use examples from compute
engine itself which is the service that
I that I work on and we're just it's an
infrastructure as a service we you know
rent VMs by the by the second and the
it's basically you know it's a a comp
very complicated complex service got a
lot of different components control
plane data plane actual VMs the
underlying host machines KVM host kernel
environment lots of different components
to think about it's also got lots of
customers and it's growing pretty pretty
rapidly so we're having to you know free
valeriy architect different pieces as
the service continues to grow and and
kind of identifying which pieces those
are and and and is kind of part of this
whole process and then there's obviously
a huge variety of use cases
infrastructure so people can use it for
whatever they currently have want to run
want to build so there's a lot of
different use cases a lot of different
requirements different performance
characteristics that different
applications need and and etc so and
this is kind of the kind of the journey
that we've been on you know since we
launched the service many years ago at
this point and and so I providing
examples from this I think will help
cement it so kind of the step one for
any kind of performance analysis that
you want to do on a complex system is
measure everything you can think of we
think in terms of what are called
service level indicators and essentially
a service level indicator is simply a
metric that you want to track like you
know number of VM exits for example or M
plus the riad the reason for the VM exit
cache misses TLB misses like that sort
of thing those are all SL is that you
can figure out how to measure and then
start analyzing over time and build
dashboards around and start correlating
with potentially performance issues that
your customers have that's a good those
are examples at the VM level higher up
in the control plane stack like latency
of API requests like every time an API
request comes in for creating a VM how
long does that take before I can respond
back like and how long does it take for
the VM to spin up and that sort of thing
so these are all these are all examples
of kind of the service level indicators
that are important and a good good
mental model is you know ask yourself
what performance related things do my
customers care about like do they care
about spin uptime of a VM probably do
they care about you know the TLB number
of TLB exits they probably don't know
how that affects their performance but
if they have a performance problem we
could use that to help troubleshoot it
so that's another good example and just
to kind of give you some numbers some
examples you're probably not going to
start out quite this big and we didn't
start out this big either but just the
jobs that run the virtual machines
themselves export over 6,000 of these
sli is like like basically
every few seconds and so we have a
massive number of these that we analyze
and collect and 2200 of those that 6000
just come from the virtual machine
monitor itself like the process that is
is sitting there kind of monitoring the
the VM and what it's doing and helping
do the i/o operations and Plus and
things like that so you know you won't
start that big but it's pretty easy to
get that big if you're building a
complicated system so here's an example
kind of I referred to a little bit
earlier like creating an instance you
know this is probably one of the most
important you know operations that a
service that sells VMs can is is doing
so customers tend to care a lot about it
and you know when we measure this this
graph is actually from an internal
dashboard that we have that measures
this kind of constantly so the vertical
axis is how long it takes to create the
VM basically from the time the compute
engine receives the API request to when
the guest OS finishes booting because we
have a signal for that that it hits the
metadata server and that's how we tell
when it finished finishes booting and
then over like the horizontal axis is
just kind of over time so we've been
measuring this for many years and so
this kind of just I just took a snapshot
of this this dashboard for a few months
I think it's over like a six month
period a while back so once I've got a
lot of metrics that I'm gathering what
do I do with them so the next set next
next step is to set targets for what
those metrics should be and we again we
started with service level indicators
that's the wrong metrics themselves now
we talk about service level objectives
and if you the service level objective
is basically like alright well here's
what I'm measuring for let's say VM
create time and it's on the order of
3540 seconds that sounds good is that
good enough
do I want to set my SLO at where I am
today
am I getting customers that are already
complaining that my vm's take too long
to spin up maybe they are that is a good
signal that tells me well where I am
today is not maybe where I need to be so
setting the SLO more aggressively and
then figuring
what I needed you to hit that is is
definitely a good way to go about it
many of you will probably if you've read
the sre handbook you'll probably
recognize some of these terms that I'm
using SLO SSL is these are all metrics
that are SRE teams use for availability
of a service as well and just they map
very well to performance availability if
you can think of it that way like is my
performance consistent and is it what
what consistent level am i delivering it
what happens when I fall out of that etc
so you set the objective your customers
and can help tell you when or how to set
that objective or what to set it to and
if there's no obvious target and you
haven't gotten any complaints about a
particular you know performance
characteristic it's probably fine to set
the SLO where it is today and then you
know when you get when you start getting
feedback from customers that it might
not be good enough then can reconsider
where you'd set it the key another key
thing about SLO s is you have to have
like kind of a similar these are all
there's a lot of details in the SRA
handbook about this as well but you have
to have a plan of action for either if I
set my SLO at a better target than where
I can deliver today you need to have a
plan to get it to that new target you
also need a reaction plan if you are if
you set it and set it to roughly where
you're delivering the performance today
the reaction plan is well what happens
if you know all of a sudden I stopped
meeting that soo like let's say I did a
push of a new binary or a new component
of my system and all of a sudden my VM
create time you know went goes below SLO
I have a certain amount of time to react
to that that's my SLO budget and the
reaction plan really needs to be very
you know quantified for something like
VM create it if we go from creating vm's
and like 60 30 40 seconds to create it
taking five minutes that could break
many customers applications and so it's
critical that the plan be immediately
actionable like if it was a roll out
then roll it back like get back to the
state where we're meeting us hello again
then go figure out what went wrong go
fix the bug that in that push whatever
the case may be so that's essentially
the Pope
of the SLO s and the importance of
having like kind of that scripted action
plan ahead of time because if you don't
have that and the first time you go out
of SLO you're scrambling to try to
figure out like what you should do there
should be a really you know into a
really established playbook for that so
just kind of give you a visual you know
example of creating this so we go back
to the create instance example and
essentially you like setting the SLO is
like drawing a line where I think is is
acceptable for creating performance and
obviously since the vertical axis is
time lower is better for VM create that
means vm's are getting created faster so
the other lines are actually some of our
internal systems that we measured like
different components and different flows
of our internal provisioning and
resource allocation mechanisms and so
that's why this graph has a lot of
different bars on it but that top bar is
the one where you know that measures
when the guest is the guest of us is
finished booting so okay the next step
of this whole process is basically go
back to step one like you are gonna do
this over and over and over especially
as you're you know iterating on your
application your user base is growing
you're finding these new architectural
limitations or you know scale-up
components that are currently your
bottleneck your you know reevaluating
where you have set s ellos because this
customer you know reported that they had
an issue at such-and-such a time you go
back and look at what your telemetry
says and we were within SLO maybe that
means we need to change the SLO and
start figuring out how to do better so
it's if you get enough customers that
are complaining about a specific thing
not working well enough or fast enough
that's usually a really good sign that
you have to you have to readjust and
rethink that SLO and basically you know
you have customers as your customer base
grows you're gonna be doing
investigations with them they're gonna
have issues you're gonna go look at your
telemetry you're not gonna find anything
that is measuring exactly what it is
that's causing them the problem and so
you're gonna work with them on a repro
you're gonna have them repro at whatever
the case you'll eventually start adding
additional SL i's defining new SLO etc
so this is a very iterative process and
will continue
you know as you find as new
investigations go on new troubleshoot
with customers you'll add new SL eyes
set new SL lows and but at some point
that kind of process stops like and you
are no longer finding new things to add
but you're still encountering customers
having issues and like it's basically
your telemetry your internal telemetry
has taken you as far as it can when it
comes to measuring what the customer
performance is and at that point you
have to become a customer of your own
service so essentially you want to build
your SL eyes in a way that it directly
reflects what the customer sees and a
good example of that is my original
metric was time to when the guest OS
finished booting that's not the whole
story
most customer applications most users if
I'm SSH like if they don't care when the
guest OS finishes booting they care when
they can actually get access to it or it
can start serving so probably needs
network to be provisioned as well so
that's basically a better customer
facing metric is when from the time we
receive the API call to when you can SSH
to it and that those new lines that you
see that orange line in the middle that
was the original guest OS boot line and
I've just added like the network
provisioning steps and network path
programming internal and external
network programming and all that - -
this graph and strange funny you know
comically enough I don't know it wasn't
funny at the time but this was when we
learned that our network provisioning
time scaled roughly with how big our
service was getting and figured out that
we have to go fix that Andry architect
network programming model to make sure
that that doesn't happen so again you
get really interesting signals when you
start measuring from the external
customers perspective rather than just
relying on your internal SL eyes so
that's basically what we end up having
to go do is we built a service that
measures performance just like the
customer so it runs benchmarks it can
run workloads
it's called perf kit benchmark err it's
open source that's on github you just
search github for peak perfect eight
benchmark or you'll find it there's also
perfect eight Explorer which is a
basically dashboarding and
lytx framework that makes it easier to
kind of build graphs kind of like the
ones that you saw in some of my examples
and you start using PKB two or a PKB
like service so what it depends on
whatever your service is but you
basically end up building something that
measures the performance like your
customers do so if it's a mobile
application you are probably gathering
telemetry out at the client and you're
like running tests that that mimic
client behavior to connecting to your
servers maybe you do it on actual mobile
devices maybe you do it on emulators
whatever the case but having an
automated framework that lets you launch
these tests and rerun them constantly in
all of your environments including your
pre-production environments like your
developer environments your staging
environments those become critical to
caching issues regressions SLO
violations etc as you develop and build
in new versions of your of your product
or application so it's a the key with
this like measuring your own service
it's a prober based system so you're
probing from the perspective of the
customer so in the VM like in the
example before we were probing by
basically running a service that
measures when I can SSH
to the VM so that means I run something
inside the VM that lets me know when
that when that succeeds and a lot of the
prober based benchmarks are the same way
you spin up a VM you install whatever
benchmark you want to run you run it and
you send a collect the results back and
and graph the results and see see how
things are going so now we'll do a quick
demo can you flip over to the demo cool
so I'm gonna run the demo I'm gonna run
is TCP round-robin which is basically as
part of the pkb suite but it's a net
perf benchmark that measures the VM to
VM latency like latency between
round-trip latency between two virtual
machines so I'm just gonna kick off the
demo first and then I'll talk a little
bit about what it's doing it takes a few
minutes so I'm gonna have to dance
around while it's actually running so
let's quickly take a quick take a look
at the actual script itself it's all the
script is doing is basically calling
PKB which is the key the main kind of
orchestration script and gives it a
bunch of arguments the key a one of the
one of the arguments is net perf config
gamal so I'll pull that up in a minute
but basically it that once the ones PKB
finishes its runs it collects all the
data in a local directory runs plotting
tool that that creates a nice CDF and
then uploads the CDF to a storage bucket
which I'll pull up as soon as it
finishes so the CDF is basically just a
distribution a graph that shows the
distribution of what the performance
looks like so if the cumulative
distribution function it's a really nice
way to look at like what my average
performance is what my longtail
performance is it kind of shows you that
that graph and I'll show you in a minute
it'll make more sense a couple notes
about the benchmarks themselves and kind
of the guidelines around this actually
let me quickly pull up the the config
file so it's pretty straightforward as
well all it's saying is I'm using n1
standard two VMs I'm using the internal
network to do my measurement not going
out through the external IPS the
benchmark I want to run how many how
many buckets histogram buckets I want to
collect for it and I actually ran the
multi zone argument which means it's
spinning up ten pairs of VMs
in three different zones across three
different regions to and and running the
tests running the are art benchmark for
60 seconds on each pair of VMs to
measure to get a good sample size of the
the round round-trip time between VMs in
those zones so let's see how it's doing
cool yeah it's still running you can see
it's SSA Qing into the VM was running
the tool and and it'll be pulling the
data back so kind of talking about a
little bit more generally about
benchmarking how to pick the how to pick
your benchmarks that you want to use
micro benchmarks are usually a good
start micro benchmark like spec in spec
CPU core mark
you know TCP RRS actually is also
considered a micro benchmark but it's a
little bit more representative of what
an actual real application might want to
do or a performance characteristic that
might be valuable to understand for a
real application micro benchmarks in and
of themselves are not always a good
indicator of what your workload is going
to experience like workloads tend to be
a lot like real workloads tend to be a
lot more complicated than that and so
you can start with micro benchmarks but
you should probably have a plan for
doing something that's more like running
things that are more like what your
customers are running for GCE that
includes running benchmarks in combat
micro benchmarks and combinations so
maybe I'll fire up you know speck in
torque or mark or whatever and at the
same time I'm also spinning up like a
net perf to do some network traffic TCP
stream maybe to push a bunch of network
either out to the Internet or some
internet endpoint or between VMs might
also spin up like an i/o stat or FIO
benchmark at the same time which is
hammering on my storage whether it's
local SSD or PD or what-have-you
so now I've got the VM actually doing a
combination of things and I can start
really getting a sense for oh well when
I start doing a lot of disk i/o this
other thing my CPU benchmark slows down
for some reason you should probably go
understand why that is because chances
are customers are probably going to be
doing things more complicated than just
running one you know CPU heavy benchmark
or CPU heavy you know workload and then
better yet then combinations and micro
benchmarks is actually workload base
benchmark so you know you can get a
sense for for GCE we know lots of
customers run no sequel databases and
Apache you know lamp stacks for cert web
serving and stuff like that so there are
open source benchmarks out there that
well you can that will measure the
throughput of a Cassandra cluster or a
like a MongoDB cluster arrow spikes got
a great set of test tools for for there
they're no sequel database in memory no
sequel database so fine you know the
benchmarks or find the workloads that
your customers are running even if it's
just a piece of it and and start you
know measuring those and then I've kind
of the the better still is when you
actually can run exactly what your
customers were running in exactly the
same config
and that's not always possible for us we
sometimes can we sometimes can't we can
get a sense for what they might be doing
have a have a meeting with them talk
about what they're doing and then try to
replicate that experience in in our in
our own environment using similar
configs sometimes we actually can work
with them and get the benchmark or get
the workload that they're actually
running get a copy of it just and they
just give us a bunch of dummy data and
we can do the same exact thing that
they're doing just with with data that
is is kind of placeholder so all right
cool so it finished
it took about if you took a few minutes
so I managed to cover the time so I'm
just gonna go to the GCS bucket now
refresh it and you can see the time
stamp on it is just you know a few
seconds ago and so it didn't it actually
worked
demo gods smiled upon me and so this is
the what I was talking about a CDF so
this shows you you know what the
distribution of latency of your VM to VM
latency is in three different zones that
we have that are across three different
regions and so the the bots like kind of
the 50th percentile this is like your
average median round-trip time between
VMs and then you can see like up toward
the top some zones are slightly better
in the long tail than others but you
know that you want the more vertical
this is the better and you know so this
is pretty pretty good indicator things
are working reasonably well here in
these zones so okay we can flip back to
the cool see so okay so now I've got my
SLO is defined I'm meeting them all I
can catch regressions in new versions of
Micah of my system at before they hit
production what now like what's kind of
the next step from here a lot of that
then becomes turning toward your focus
toward making your systems more
efficient you're probably you know got a
backlog of summary architect and you
need to do depending on how fast your
your customer base is growing or your
users or how your user base is growing
so you know am i spending way too much
money on solving this problem am I you
know is there something I could be doing
more efficient is there some product
that I can use that that gives me a
better TCO like total cost per whatever
it is I'm trying to do and kind of to
that point it really helps to start
think about what is your cost for
performance so like what is it costing
me to hit you know for example that like
the 30 second create time for vm's like
how much more would it cost me
engineering investment wise resource
wise maybe I can shard my control plane
even further to you know let it scale up
further what's that going to cost me to
get another 10 seconds off of my VM
create time right so thinking about the
performant cost and cost of the
performance you're trying to get and how
much it would take to get to the kind of
the next level of performance really
helps with with this process you know
another example is if I'm doing ML image
training I'm training a machine learning
model for to do image recognition you
know during the training
like what's my it's you know pennies per
image right like hopefully it's not even
pennies per image if it is you're
probably doing it wrong and then you
know once you've got a train what's my
classification cost like what is it you
know how many pennies per classification
and my am i spending and can I do better
than that so you know kind of find the
products that fit your patterns you know
what you want to do you know these are
some examples for GCE but this is you
know I think this is fairly generally
applicable you want to find discount
like discounts where you can get it so
like for our committed use discounts are
really good for anytime you've got like
kind of a steady amount of workload like
steady number of VMs if you buy
committed use discount that kind of
covers the cot like the number of
resources that you're using for where
the Green Line is you're getting a
really really good discount up to like
57% I think discount if you buy a
three-year si UD for the cost of that
steady-state used a amount of resources
so it works really well if you have
diurnal workloads that changes the
equation a little bit but you know for
the steady-state stuff see UDS is a
really great way to save a bunch of
money sorry too quick
wrong button preemptable VMs if you've
just got a batch style computation that
you need to launch you know watch a
bunch of VMs do some computation then
just
delete them all preemptively ends is a
great model for that there are 80%
cheaper than normal VMS and as long as
you can handle if you've got a worker
based system that can handle a worker
going away it remembers what work it
gave to the one that just died and gives
it to another one this is a really good
way to save a lot of money as well
custom machine types it's another
feature that we have for GCE that
basically makes it so that you can you
know set your create your VM to fit your
workload not your workload try to figure
out how to get your workload to scale up
to use the rest of the resources that
you have on a fixed fixed shape VM
another other examples you know the ala
carte config that we all a cart nature
of being able to add things like local
SSD different GPUs you can add that to
kind of any machine type or any VM as
opposed to only being able to pick for a
subset of VM so that's also another you
know way to help save money if it turns
out that being able to run your workload
and and maybe you find a library that's
optimized to do a specific computation
against the GPU and it's like you know
significantly cheaper than doing it on
CPU like being able to add a GPU to to
the VM is is pretty helpful without
having to spend a bunch of money also on
local SSD perhaps or whatever else might
be attached so just to kind of recap
what do we start by just measuring
everything you can think of think about
what's important to your customers focus
on that define the SLO s based on either
where your customers are telling
complaining or if they're not
complaining probably setting them to
where they are where it is today is fine
you're gonna go through that process a
lot you're gonna get customers
complaining you're gonna investigate
you're gonna find new things you need to
measure new SLO s you need to set SLO
existing s ellos you need to set higher
or lower depending on what you're
measuring and then eventually you'll
have to start measuring as your
customers do or from your customers
perspective and and building a service
or it might not be a service but that's
an easy way to easy concept conceptual
way to think about it build a service
for measuring the performance of your
system as if it's from what the
customers experience so just wanted to
give a shout out to some folks that
helped me with this
al Hamel he he runs the performance
engineering team they built PKB they
built the infrastructure to run all that
stuff on internally for GCE he works
with all of our you know very intimately
involved with a lot of our customers
working on analyzing their performance
and stuff like that Eric enge : actually
thank him for my tempo of succeeding
because of firewalls and whatnot and
then Brian was our one of our marketing
people that that helped me rehearse
basically counting my arms
[Music]